i'm going to show you the only cure that
you'll ever need for candida also i'm
going to show you how to never have
candida
ever again and this is all based on some
recent information that i stumbled on
that i want to share with you because
it's actually quite interesting what is
candida candida is a type of yeast or a
fungus
and to really understand how to get rid
of it you just have to understand
exactly what it is and how it can
overgrown in our body there's a couple
facts that you need to know about
candida number one
um you normally should have some amount
of candida living on your body okay in
your mouth in your digestive tract and
many other locations
the problem with candida is when it
overgrows and there are quite a few
different strains of candida out there
there's like 150 different types and
some are more pathogenic than others and
so a yeast or a candida is just one type
of microorganism that is living
inside your body as well as
superficially you also have bacteria
you also have mold
and you even have viruses that actually
can help you as well there they actually
keep bacteria in check now with candida
it's the bacteria that keeps this
candida in check
and so without bacteria you'll get this
overgrowth of candida
and the single biggest cause is
antibiotics
they're called an immunosuppressive
therapy so when you take an antibiotic
it wipes out the good bacteria and now
we have nothing to counter
this overgrowth of yeast
but there's more to the story so stay
with me
as a side note and this is very
interesting
out of all the antibiotics that are sold
in the u.s
nearly 80 percent of them are sold in
agriculture
only 20 percent are sold through like a
doctor's office
so our animals are given antibiotics not
because they necessarily have some type
of sickness
but it allows that animal to live in a
stressful environment it allows for
or a dirtier environment
or a less nutritious environment because
if you're giving this antibiotic to this
animal it can at least temporarily lower
the infection rate not to mention it
will put on weight and there's and the
problem with that topic is there's a lot
of secrecy
in this area it's very difficult to find
um data on the sales of antibiotics and
especially in the us it's very difficult
to track down if there was an outbreak
of e coli for example or salmonella it's
very difficult to track where that
outbreak originated from
versus in europe um they do track that
but in the us they don't track that and
so you're probably wondering where does
this e coli or
salmonella come from well it comes from
the manure that is put on the soils that
we grow these vegetables with the manure
from animals who had antibiotics
who then ended up with super bugs and
microbes that
cannot be killed by antibiotics because
the more antibiotics are given to an
animal or a human you develop antibiotic
resistance
so this whole focus on antibiotics is
not just about you taking antibiotics
it's about the antibiotics given to
animals it's about the antibiotics given
to animals that then create manure that
we use in soils that we grow our food on
so if you're a vegan or a vegetarian and
you don't consume these animal products
well you might be getting indirectly
from the soil those plants are growing
on and so the problem is everything's
going to sterilization we have to
sterilize our food we have to radiate
our food to make sure there's no
pathogens we have to overcook our food
to prevent these pathogenic microbes
from going in our body and this is why
even if you were to buy a chicken a
commercial chicken
and you cook it well when you cut it up
on your cutting board
there's a real high risk of having this
contaminated cutting board that then
gets on your fingers that gets in your
body and it can create food poisoning so
that's a little data on antibiotics now
what are the symptoms of candida
well the biggest symptom is that you
have this
craving for carbohydrates because
candida love
carbs number two you have itchiness in
your private parts it could be in the
vaginal area the anal area number three
a white tongue it's called oral thrush
before you're more tired why because the
candida is also using up a lot of your
nutrients so you're gonna be nutrient
deficient number five utis number six
bloating and digestive issues number
seven sinus congestion and number eight
skin issues dermatitis it can also be
athlete's foot psoriasis things like
that and number nine achy joints
those are all the symptoms of having
candida now the next thing is extremely
interesting
candida does not like living in an acid
environment it loves to live in an
alkaline environment and so killing off
your microbes kill off something called
acidophilus that's acid creating
microbes so you kill those off and guess
what your ph changes your ph starts to
increase and you become more alkaline in
your large intestine
and this is a perfect environment for
candida and the problem is when candida
eats the sugar that's what they live on
the byproduct is ammonium and ammonia is
very alkaline so then having candida
makes the environment more alkaline for
more candida to thrive in and also i
forgot one more symptom about candida
you might have like
ammonia breath
because this is a gas that is being
released
from the byproduct of this yeast or
candida infection
and you'll usually have this ammonia
breath all right there's a couple of
things that will make you alkaline too
consuming
sugar
yeah that's right too much sugar makes
you more alkaline not more acid this is
why like a diabetic who has high sugar
well first of all that high sugar is
going to feed the um the candida and
secondly it's going to create an
alkaline environment so we have the
feeding of the candida and then we have
the environment itself the alkalinity
the next thing that makes an alkaline
environment for candida to thrive in is
stress that's right
stress
alkalizes the body interesting because
you're losing the acids when you go
through stress
so anything that one creates cortisol
will make you more alkaline
increasing the environment for candida
the next thing is birth control pills as
well as being pregnant
both will alkalize the body increasing
the environment for candida to thrive
and then we also have antacids right
they alkalize the body increasing your
risk of candida and so all of these
things can worsen candida
so what can you do well number one you
need to run your body on ketones
ketones are acid and that will help to
re-establish the ph
plus going on a ketogenic diet lowers
the amount of sugar which the candida
thrives on so we're going to basically
start them off with the ketogenic diet
and of course i would also along with
that do intermittent fasting all right
next thing is probiotics you must be
taking a probiotic
acidophilus included because we want to
start building up the microbes to help
keep the overgrowth of candida in check
next thing in the list is fermented
vegetables like sauerkraut or kimchi
both of those products have probiotic
and prebiotic fibers that feed your
microbes next thing that's really good
is oregano oil
garlic is also another good thing but
oregano oil is a really good
antimicrobial without the side effects
next thing on the list is apple cider
vinegar why because it's acidic any acid
is really good to help kill off candida
and this is why coconut oil is also
really good because it has three main
acids and one of them is a very potent
anti-fungal so we don't want to forget
coconut oil because that's important you
can also do mct oil as well so that is
the six things that you need to do for
candida to make sure it never ever comes
back now the next video that's the most
appropriate for you to watch and i think
you'll like this one is the one on
friendly bacteria check it out i put it
up right now